one of the secrets that the slow cooking
is to be robust and really get stuck in
big bold flavors work brilliantly well
so don't be precious this is gutsy
cooking that is absolute best
these are lamb breasts a beautiful cheap
cut and it sort of tucked alongside the
rib
they've been boned out the skin has been
taken off I'm gonna roll them stuff them
and braise them braising simply means
cooking in liquid on a low heat making
the meat divinely tender now open them
up and give them a really good season
season them both sides inside and out
really important doesn't look like a
real weighty dense cut of meat but once
these beautifully slow braise it's just
like melting lamb it's incredible on a
season the breasts with some dried or
Agana
put it heat in there some chili flakes
lemon zest just amazing salted anchovies
in their mouth they almost melt inside
of a lamb so the balance of flavors work
beautifully now pull it down toward you
and roll that nice and tightly
so I'm looking for string just need to
tie them three times one at each end and
one in the middle I fell in love with
this dish years ago when I first started
working in Paris because we had all the
lamb in from the Pyrenees nice thing is
they can be done the day before pan on
olive oil in get that oil nice and hot
lamb in really important to you it's a
nice color on there whilst they're
browning slice the onion but I was gonna
be cooking for two hours so don't slice
the onions too thinly otherwise they'll
burn garlic and leave whole I've got a
color on them that beautiful take them
out onions in and garlic straight in
love it that's a secret about slow
braising you never change pans why all
the goodness isn't that one pan a few
chili seeds in there are gana nice pinch
a little bit of lemon in there and I do
the onions what I did to the lamb
next my capers fire them off get them
exploding the bottom the pan they get
nice and crisp in next my black olives
now white wine
mmm bring that up to the boil deglazing
the pan as well rinsing the bottom of
that pan and now the flavor in there
it's just extraordinary
now rare that Tomatoes puncher those
plum tomatoes
then simply place the lamb breast back
in the pot and remember to taste
[Music]
[Applause]
that's nice lid on into the oven 172 two
and a half hours and forget about it
well beautiful all that was reduced down
to this amazing nice tomato sauce and
the lamb it's kept its color it's
braised beautifully very carefully
little bits there
it's nice off pull off the little bits
of stream this is why I get really
excited the secret is not to slice it
too thinly and smell the lemon
hard to believe when you slice through
the center there but that is a very
cheap cut of meat I'm celebrating I love
this I mean it's just incredible
pick up the tomatoes and the olives and
the onions I'm amazing rich for horse
take the lamp sort of just sit it on it
looks incredible that for me is why
chefs get so excited with cheap cuts
because the end results are incredible
delicious breast of lamb with lemon and
Chavez chili and Ariana
great in fresh ginger
add dried shiitake mushrooms that have
been soaked in water I'm just hitting
the bottom of the pan without tomato
puree and we call it cooking out of
smart puree